hey what up guys Emilio Rojas catch me
on the bootleg Kev podcast let's go
bullet care podcast special guests in
here my guy Emilio Rojas what up man
welcome man so first of all Emilio how's
it living downtown L.A we're just
talking you've been in L.A for a while
now I've been in La for a while I was
decided it was a good idea to move to
[ __ ] goddamn Skid Row bro I don't
live I don't live in a tent bro I'm not
like how has it been living in a tent
and using porta potties it was important
when the last time you shot in front of
someone's stew in the corner yo downtown
is crazy bro in L.A but this is La in
general man like coming from no La in
general for sure yeah but downtown
is [ __ ] insane well because it's all
localized into like a small area yeah
like Skid Row is some crazy [ __ ] I've
been around the world I've never seen
anything like that yeah Skid Row is very
uh
you know it's always been crazy so it's
not like anything new but it's it's
definitely like like people choose to be
there I think well I think some people
choose to be there and I know like a lot
of people are just getting dropped off
like when the prisons get overwhelmed or
there's no mental health facilities they
just get dropped off that's where I
think when you get let out of County the
bus just that's what I think I I think I
heard that but I can't speak I think you
shouldn't think things
I think people are just getting dropped
off yeah no that's what I that's what I
was told oh I just never verified it
yeah uh shout out to Skid Row man yeah
I like watching uh just random
documentaries or like random Youtube
Vlogs about skid row because when I walk
over there man you walk over there no
not maybe not Instagram I don't think
kev's ever walked in school just
downtown in general I wear them ah it's
just everywhere what's uh where's all
the clubs at down there I've been
[ __ ] walking through crowd smoke yeah
oh for sure bro yeah Spring Street
walking through crack smoke 100 crack
smoke you see people shoot up like I saw
this guy
who was like dressed like a [ __ ]
legit like you know [ __ ] hypebeast
young white kid [ __ ] obviously had
money with Supreme doubt [ __ ] fire
ass like hard to find New Balances on
right
and I saw him walking and I was like uh
I was like walking past him when I was
going into a spot and I was walking back
the other way he was like huddled up
with all the crackheads and he like took
his little [ __ ] his little you know
his little man thing and he opens and he
pulls out the brillo and the crack and
he starts smoking crack with all the
homeless guys and I was like [ __ ] like
it must be funner like that can't be a
lonely drug like it must be funner to be
like yo I'm gonna go downtown we'll find
some people to smoke crack with because
it's better that way it's a social drug
for sure they're out there passing like
you want to be like the rich kid smoking
crack alone at home nah that's when you
really really lost you just want to be
the rich kid smoking crack with it with
all the home with all the other
crackheads yeah and just be like yo I'll
see you guys in two years I'll be right
here with you LA's crazy because it's
like you'll be in a place like skid row
and there'll be like a chick with like
fake titties homeless getting piped I
don't even know but it's like you know
she came here for something else she was
doing whatever and then just the city
just got her she got on that fetty WAP
yeah something fentanyl yeah something
bro that meth meth is Big out here
Fentanyl
he focused on Netflix
bro I heard that they're smoking
fentanyl now like they don't even want
they know what it is they're like no we
don't want uh we want fentanyl they're
used to smoking it now yeah they built
up the tolerance imagine building up a
tolerance this well that's what happens
with opioids right like you had opium
then morphine then heroin yeah you know
it's just oxes yeah it just gets
stronger and stronger and now they're
just like give me the fetty give me the
[ __ ] let's do it it's crazy another
wild downtown's wild have you tried
fentanyl
I've been I've been pretty pretty
fortunate to uh not have tried yeah just
make sure you're careful because you
walk through the wrong cloud of smoke
down there you might [ __ ] know oh
yeah I might have tried fentanyl on
accident a couple times that's terrible
by the way free fetty WAP
totally unrelated what happened he got
locked up he's in prison right now for
what
I don't know if it was fentanyl but he
got it was some drug [ __ ] he got he got
hit pretty hard I don't want to speak on
his case because I don't know the facts
but he's in uh he's in yeah he's locked
up he took a plea jeez that sucks man
yeah so what's been going on with you
man I'm just working man I just dropped
a little like remix mixtape on industry
beats called grip tape because I've been
skating a lot so I used to skateboard a
lot when I was a kid you've been skating
a lot yeah well you why you look so
shocked I'm good bro I didn't know you
were a skater I can skate really good so
you just randomly decided to pick it
back up because I was having a lot of
anxiety you know like at the beginning
of the pandemic like I was like yo I'm a
grown man having like these anxiety
symptoms that I never dealt with before
in my life like so now you just sort of
Escape
them out because skateboarding is like a
really like meditation like activity
right you have to really focus like if
you [ __ ] up your foot placement or
something because you're thinking about
some other [ __ ] you're gonna fall and
like you know bust your ass so you
really have to focus and it allows you
to really disconnect
so the mixtape is you jumping on other
beats that was the one we just dropped
yeah that was uh I got like a bunch of
people on it I got um
like a bunch of like the homies we just
wrapped on a bunch of [ __ ] we wrapped on
like uh kick push just you know because
I've been skating that's natural had to
do it you know then a milli because
that's my name you know but now we're
moving on we're about to drop some real
music
um end of this month end of October so
with the mixtape you obviously can't put
it on DSP so it's on the one website
industrybeats.com I've never even heard
of that what did you just say it was on
we we dropped on industry beats like
they were recorded on top of Beats oh
industry dog I thought that was like a
new platform I'm sorry
I thought you were like yo it's on we
dropped it on industry beats and I'm
like oh that must be like a new depth if
the new dat fifth nah so it's on DatPiff
no we didn't we just put it right
through it on YouTube okay SoundCloud on
YouTube yeah because you should put it
on that pip I know right why not I was
just okay yeah big shots to [ __ ] that
picture and there's my mixtapes app a
lot of people use that oh [ __ ] look at
you you [ __ ] up my whole life right
now yeah have about to take over my
market shout out to YouTube man so you
pretty much just a lot of YouTube [ __ ] a
lot of YouTube [ __ ] because I was uh I
was finalizing a business situation so
now that that's all wrapped
because I wasn't trying to go back into
the label system or the Distribution
Company system per se right
um
so I wanted to do something a little
different so as you sent me like a
preview a new video well you sent me
your new video yeah you probably only
previewed it because you're fake busy no
I watch I watch okay I watched the whole
thing I'm just fine you were like
chopping like I told you it's like some
vintage Emilio chopping on here vintage
vintage yeah we uh it's a it's a nod to
that the the fat John punch it twins
which was a nod to Deep Cover yeah so
um obviously being Latino like I'm super
influenced by pun Joe of course of
course and yeah I definitely like
reference the the dead in the middle of
the literally yeah I had to so now
because I I feel like you had like a you
were you were kind of like dabbling a
bit into Spanish [ __ ] right trying to
make more like uh Spanglish yeah kind of
I feel like you were kind of trying to
make more records that weren't
necessarily
maybe what your core fan base would
expect from you for a while that was
like a lot of external pressures for
those types of Records yeah yeah so you
know I had to kind of take it back a
little bit I feel like when you have
like a I feel like that you you have you
busted a hard left
I feel like if you're gonna go there you
got to make it a gradual laugh well you
know I was getting pressure man like it
was one of those things like yo we're
gonna open a marketing budget you're
like yo you're Hispanic you speak
Spanish what are you doing that was
literally that's literally I know what
the conversation was oh you probably
have it a lot with oh for sure yeah I
know the combo they want to take you in
you got to do records that we see NE
Yandel God bless amazing artists but
like it doesn't really make sense with
Emilio it's just you just got to get
there like gradually I'm just not a
[ __ ] I don't do reggaeton I don't do
right I think like at the end of the day
like
I think your fans have a certain like
love for some of the stuff you do it's
very transparent it's very personal it's
very lyric driven and I feel like some
of the stuff I was hearing from you I
was like oh dude it wasn't this is
interesting
this is a hard left well it was like we
were trying to mix the two right so I've
always made records about girls I've
always done like breakup records and
stuff but like why don't we put it on
like a Latin Rhythm right okay cool I
mean I'm Latino I like that those type
of Records it's cool you know I've been
making records for a while so like it's
no harm in experimenting yeah it worked
I mean listen how did those records do
they did all right like did you did you
notice I could open your fan base and or
did it also piss off your regular fan
base a little well I think what I did
which was smart and just not even
deliberate but just what I've always
done is just I've always like stayed
lyrical even in those spaces of course
yeah yeah so I mean you're a [ __ ]
beast so it's like you can't help but be
incredible at rapping thank you hey
that's I appreciate that thank you yeah
it's our it's our it's like not like
people who rap as good as you it's it's
like no matter what you're gonna do it's
gonna be dope in terms of like the
lyricism you know yeah so I think you
know it satisfied people a little bit
and I was still trying to give my my
core
records yeah you know like we we tried
to walk the line and I still you know
like I don't think it was inauthentic to
me as a human being because like I like
girls and kids of course maybe from a
marketing standpoint it could have been
done a little bit more deliberately so
would you say the new stuff coming out
is a little bit more like kind of back
to like what got you here type [ __ ] well
it's like well obviously you put a
mixtape out which is very [ __ ] you
know I just wanted to rap bro that's
what I mean like that's very vintage of
you yeah and it was it wasn't really a
lot of thought put into it right which
is great sometimes that's the best thing
you just don't oh man I'm sure you've
been through this just overthinking your
music [ __ ] can be sometimes the worst
finished is better than perfect yeah all
the time bro and it's like when you have
all these people like yo we're gonna
open this is a smash we're gonna do this
this and this like from the labels or
whatever and you're trying to deliver
and then they never deliver on their
promises or whatever
it it muddies the waters
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our folks at mybookie
ladies and gentlemen [ __ ] NFL
season is approaching it's my favorite
time of the year God damn it it's good
times and the Rams versus the bills is
happening kicking off the whole regular
season and there's no way to get ready
for that regular season like getting
ready for that winning season all right
I'm talking about putting some
[ __ ] money in your pocket you
could be a veteran better like me or you
could be a first time better and you
just want to get a little taste of the
action my bookie has got you because
right now they got that double deposit
bonus if you sign up at mybookie.ag
right now go to my bookie it's quick and
easy let's say you put 250 bucks in you
get 500 to gamble with that's right it's
a double deposit bonus but you have to
use the promo code
bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g it's also in the
description of this video you can just
click the link and you're in there so go
to mybookie.com use that double deposit
bonus by using the promo code that you
got to register today use it and let's
get this NFL season [ __ ] cracking I'm
talking listen I don't even know the
line of the Rams Bills game it's about a
week out only some change away depending
on what the [ __ ] you're watching this
but
Bill's money line what are we doing all
right my bookie sign up use that promo
code bootleg right now and get that
double deposit bonus if you put in a
thousand dollars you get two thousand
dollars to gamble with you put a hundred
you get 200. it's that [ __ ] easy my
bookie go run it up let's get back to
the interview
100
so when we were doing that we were still
like dropping the lyrical [ __ ] but this
new [ __ ] is like it's more dysfunctional
hmm you know how many uh well first of
all you got the name of the project yeah
breaking point two
yeah because I did a mixtape a couple
years ago with DJ Green Lantern and
Billionaire Boys Club called breaking
point it was a couple of years ago maybe
longer I mean my concept of time is
[ __ ]
wait when was the first Green Lantern
tape you did maybe 10 years ago
it might have been 10 years ago okay
wait wait 2011 2012. so that's the same
one that's the the sequel yeah it took a
while okay I just want to make sure I'm
not crazy this is like a Terminator
pretty sure that was like 11 years ago
this is like Avatar Avatar too it might
have been 12 years ago I think it was
2011. so 11. yeah I think it's more
2011. yeah yeah I don't know you
probably know better than I do I think
it was 2010 2010 I'm gonna look it up we
should look it up let's look it up we
have these [ __ ] million dollar
devices in our hands I'm in I'm in I'm
because I'm trying to remember when I
first
I feel like I was working at Power I
don't know yeah you might have been uh
might have been nah Breaking Point
it says 2013 on here 2012. I think 2011
because that's over 2011 it says here
Amelia Rose Breaking Point produced by
Jake 2011. so that means the the record
because that was when everything wasn't
project like we would run singles before
projects right it wasn't like a post
campaign okay so yeah it was about 10
years ago let's just say 10. We'll
average it to 10. a cool decade a cool
you know little dime was that your that
was your first or that was your first I
think second that was just saying okay
because maybe it was this it was the
first one that um that people cared that
I had like
came to you for because I remember
finding you through my boy uh Slim in
Phoenix you did a drop for him once for
me shout out to dearly departed clothing
um but yeah shout out to you man so it's
been 10 years it's been not a couple
well dude I don't know man I'm just
[ __ ] my time my time thing is [ __ ]
yeah it's all good man uh you've [ __ ]
you're a veteran I'm a vet yeah you're a
vet I want what's mine bro I want like I
feel like I haven't gotten what I
deserve so I'm like after it right now
what do you think like has been because
I feel like there's been a lot of
artists who are kind of from your era
that maybe went like a little
underappreciated maybe a little under
the radar maybe feel the same way you
feel what what would you attribute that
to I think it's a mix right like
regardless of like the fact that the
Latin [ __ ] is huge now right when I
entered the space I was a brand new
artist a brand new idea like all the
Latino artists in the past historically
have been like very
like more Gangsta more Street like you
were like kind of like late blog era
yeah I missed the early I missed like
the the blog era where everybody's
popping yeah yeah so I think it was a
mix of like the labels not knowing what
box to put me in right and then um
kind of like catching the tail end of
the blog era and not really like wanting
to like transition to the streaming era
like we kind of fought it a little bit
right we're like why am I giving records
away for free you know and then um
you know I had like some personal [ __ ]
like some like I was with violator for a
little bit and like when Chris Lighty
passed it like it [ __ ] me up a little
bit right right right right
um I [ __ ] a lot of people up for sure
exactly so rest in peace to Chris and
you know just I had to get my [ __ ]
together I wasn't ready emotionally to
do a lot of the things that I'm like
feel like I'm ready for now like one
thing they don't tell you about in music
is like yeah you could be talented you
can make records but if your mindset
isn't right you're not gonna I feel like
you're just not gonna be given those
opportunities
um you know like or maybe you're not
ready for them exactly or you can't even
recognize that they're there to activate
them yeah it's like yeah because like at
that time you know I had A-list artists
calling me and [ __ ] and like trying to
insert me into situations that they were
developing and I didn't even really know
at the time like how to capitalize on
those opportunities who's trying to sign
you I forget who it was there was some
there's there was some talk about you
signing with somebody we went to uh we
were talking with rose I was gonna say I
thought it was MMG yeah there was a
couple of other ones that weren't like
publicized I just keep it private I
remember the MMG one yeah thing I'm
thinking of what how far did that get
down the line because he was trying to
sign a lot he was trying to sign you
Nipsey uh [ __ ] Don Kennedy
um
I mean Rose I think he was in the middle
of changing labels from like Warner to
Def Jam it was Warner yeah well it was
Warner to Atlantic okay one or two
Atlantic yeah because that was when uh
MMG originally was on war and then there
was a big I don't know what happened but
then everything from MMG ended up on
Atlantic yeah exactly and I think we we
weren't organized on my end you know
when I had like the spotlight at that
moment it was accidental it wasn't
deliberate like I had done a record with
like big crit and laws and I remember
the shots of law was from Tampa big
shouts what happened to loss I think
another one got caught up laws I think
the team he was working with took the
joy out of the creative wasn't he
working with Justice League I can't say
names definitively so you're saying the
Justice League took the creative process
out of I'm just kidding no I mean Rook I
love rook and I love the Justice League
they're some of my favorite producers of
all time but I think you know when you
deal with certain people they haven't
popped an artist off let's be honest
they're [ __ ] incredible
but I mean they they also signed a homie
from Tampa what was the kid's name Prime
nice kid from Tampa I mean I lived in
Tampa and Justin's [ __ ] legendary
they're some of my favorite producers of
all time I mean they have like the best
Rick Ross songs of all time ever yeah
but like outside of the Rick Ross stuff
I think they gave him his sound you know
they gave him his sound I really and I
really wish that like I really wish
they'd I I wish they did more [ __ ] like
I don't maybe they are and I'm just not
hip to it you know but I'll say this
laws was fire laws is super talented
yeah and I don't know if it was like the
label side of things I don't know where
but somewhere along the line he lost the
love first because he was hard I think
he's dropping records again now though
but I think that's why he stepped back
you should reach out there Lorac let's
reach out to laws let's bring Tampa laws
I [ __ ] with laws heavy good dude that
was kind of yeah he was kind of like
late blog era guy too you guys are kind
of the same kind of you know yep yeah so
so you did the record with laws and crit
yeah and it just like the way I came off
on the record put a lot of attention on
me that I wasn't ready for like I didn't
even have [ __ ] records done right
right so it was like we were in a
situation where I was like as you know
right you got to have [ __ ] ready to go
for sure immediately and we were just
chasing our tail yeah so
I had to step back pause build up like a
folder a hard drive hundreds of Records
videos all that [ __ ] and just get ready
to execute so when uh you did you like
meet face to face with Ross about the
whole [ __ ] yeah we flew out um
or I flew out to Oakland one time with
him I was in Philly with him one time
was Meek Mill there in Philly I don't I
don't think so I think it was on they
were on tour with Lil Wayne yeah at the
time there's a there's a few artists on
image like I love to pill shot of my guy
p i double Little Pill it was super dope
too he's super dope yeah I don't know
what happened man he was so fire though
I kind of know happened but shout out to
pill he's a he's a great guy sometimes
your demons get the best of you that's
what I'll say oh yeah I don't know pill
was a beast man but yeah nah that that I
feel like you were part of like a dope
class of rappers I just feel like
sometimes man like at the end of the day
man like you said sometimes you're not
ready sometimes
I had to be humble too I was a dick bro
99 of this [ __ ] too is luck
like people think that like it's hard
work it's personal you got to be ready
to like be persevering persevered
through all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
also gotta catch a break yep and that's
the thing right I think when you're
talented I think you can create
opportunities right by being consistent
right right but if you're not consistent
and those don't matter just come it
[ __ ] you yeah for sure and also like I
was a cocky little prick bro yeah you're
a little cocky yeah I think it's cool
with me but I I felt that for sure yeah
I had to be humble you had rapper
syndrome yeah that happens all with a
lot of guys yep I had to be humbled and
I feel like you know some people never
got humbled and they just accelerated
you know popped off by the way humbled
what you just did look like the Hitler
salute we're going to point out that's
not what he did that's not what I did he
said sorry anyway no um
uh yeah so what would you say humbled
you
life bro like having situations that I
was planning on right not pan out yeah
you know and like I was I was with a
team of talented individuals and we
weren't necessarily always seeing eye to
eye and
when things you know when when [ __ ] that
you're planning on happening doesn't
happen and it happens repeatedly you
start to realize like all right maybe
I'm the problem right you know so I had
to look internally and like really
examine my behavior my level of
preparation for certain things like you
know when you come to an interview you
got to make sure you have your bars
ready right you know it was different
then I was like I got this yeah yeah and
it's like now I'm like you know what
like
this is a spot that a lot of people
would kill to be in even the spot that
I'm in now yeah for sure so I can't take
that for granted and I can't act like
it's owed to me I can't act like any
relationship is owed to me or any
interaction is owed to me that's what
people respect yeah most people really
need to walk that way man yep a lot of
people don't and it's it's catching up
to a lot of people it is and then they
end up like oh [ __ ] and by then all
their [ __ ] relationships are burnt to
the ground bro no that's real did you
ever like like uh I feel like a lot of
people who folk with psychedelics
or eat a bunch of animals now you know
what's crazy I've been given so many
[ __ ] mushrooms lately you haven't
tried them I've never done them you
should do them man well you're not
you're kind of like a pretty straight
edge I'm pretty clean yeah I don't
[ __ ] drink [ __ ] kombucha and [ __ ]
I like kombucha you know I like the the
fermented mushroom juice dishes that's
what it is right it's like a [ __ ]
mushroom it should tastes like hippie
soda it's good I mean it should tastes
like [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] Shaggy from the [ __ ]
Scooby-Doo's ball here
that kombucha's got awful like yo it's a
probiotic like I I so what it tastes
like [ __ ] yeah it does I it was an
acquired taste for sure yeah but sounds
like most alcohol I feel like like
alcohol is terrible yeah people need to
stop acting like it's good yeah alcohol
[ __ ] sucks you like it because it
gets you drunk right
but no one's drinking tequila and being
like damn that I mean there's people who
say I mean because there is a difference
between shitty tequila and good I heard
yeah some of it's smoother than yeah for
sure but it's still in taste like you
wouldn't like if you knew you could
drink an entire gallon of it
and nothing would happen to you and you
wouldn't get you drunk if it was just
like a flavor of a soda you wouldn't
drink it because it tastes like [ __ ]
yeah like if you went to like McDonald's
and they had tequila on the [ __ ] the
soda machine like you wouldn't pick it
because you wouldn't want to drink a
whole cup of that yeah it's [ __ ]
terrible I mean it's alcohol it's like
but I'm saying like let's say take the
alcohol and the what would happen to you
if you actually drink a full cup of
tequila take all that out of it let's
say it was just a drink that tasted that
way nobody would drink it it's [ __ ]
terrible yeah but it's for a purpose
it's a purpose you get drunk 100 yeah
same thing with beer [ __ ] beer I love
Corona but you know I love it because it
gets me [ __ ] up
you're like oh [ __ ] playing dominoes
on the Block except in the Coronas
appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at Blue chew they got you
handled fellas and Etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick Bluetooth
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels I
mean like LeBron his first three seasons
with the heat type levels I mean your
wife will thank you for it everybody
will thank you for it [ __ ] even if you
just take a blue chew and jerk your dick
it's a it's a stronger jerk I swear to
God stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're
gonna be beating your dick like a stole
something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg right now and you're gonna
get your first month free and this is
the great thing about Bluetooth the same
active ingredients as Viagra and scialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discrete
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
thank me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the Bluetooth he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview uh yo it's
crazy I was I didn't go to your hometown
but um I went to uh to top in New York
Upstate New York I went to Buffalo for a
day uh which isn't too far from where
you're from right hour yeah it's a whole
way different up there huh it's
different it's it feels like the South
Loki yeah it definitely if like Buffalo
felt a little like Detroit because I've
been to both places well that's I mean
Rochester Buffalo you have any any city
in America that had like a lot of
prosperity during like the era of
production when we had like factories
and plants and [ __ ] when you take that
away you're just going to see it
economically depressed Wasteland right
there's someone else from Rochester
that's I feel like I dispatch
Ito yeah shout out to Rochester man yeah
Rock Town rock Town Flower City 585. is
there flowers there yeah lilacs lilacs
lilac's beautiful what's that look like
it's like a like small petals it's like
a like a kind of like grown on a I don't
know how to describe it it's beautiful
nice little how close to Canada is that
uh like an hour and a half if you go
hang out in Canada when you're growing
up nah not really so go to Toronto I've
been to Toronto but not not when I was
growing oh once when I was young you're
pretty traveled yeah I've been around
I've been around your opinion what city
has the most beautiful women Miami I
agree yeah because Miami is like a
Melting Pot of all like the women from
Latin America which is all I love
if you go to Miami and you go to
McDonald's yeah the chick work in the
drive-through is a seven at least yeah
she'll be bad it's wild well that's in
the U.S like if you go to like
Caracas Venezuela or some [ __ ] I don't
even want to get into that yeah because
if I go out there I'm getting divorced
I couldn't I couldn't go I could I just
couldn't no Columbia trips and you
Colombia is the problem if I go there if
I go to Brazil I'm not sure what would
happen
but with that being said Miami's
beautiful place Miami's Miami's fire and
yeah I feel like Miami too is uh out of
all the cities in the U.S
I won't even say it so shout out to my
wait what no no I'm saying we'll just
say we got to give love to Miami I'm
gonna be there for the last Billboard
Awards at the end of the month oh okay
let's go get yourself some [ __ ] arepa
some cachapa get some Venezuelan food uh
I went to uh
I've never had that kind of food bro
let's let's [ __ ] let's make that
happen I barely just had pupusas like
three years ago what for the first time
when I moved to LA it's the same type of
Masa like cornmeal so pupusas is like
for people who don't know it's El
Salvadorian food I'm from Phoenix we
only have Mexican food and if there is
papoosas in Phoenix it can't be great
um but out here in L.A it's kind of like
it's like probably I would venture to
say there's
probably more El salvadorians here than
anywhere else in the U.S yeah I would
probably agree yeah so I don't have the
census in front of me so like the the
the pupusas are amazing yeah if you go
to the right place it's like game
changing so like shout out to pupusas
but I never obviously love Cuban food oh
[ __ ] awesome there's like that really
old restaurant
um
it's in Miami it's uh it's in Versailles
yeah Versailles yeah that's where we
went that [ __ ] was gas whatever size
good have you been up to Porto's
you know what it is I'm gonna be honest
about Porto's When someone tells me it's
the number one rated restaurant in the
country for on Yelp when I go there I
just expect to ejaculate when I eat the
food well I mean Bakery I didn't come
that's all I'm gonna say it's like one
of those things man La I feel like La
food is real hit or miss too Porto's is
fire it is good I love the meat the
meatballs like the little Papa again
those are fire I love uh they got a
chicken they got both their chicken
sandwiches they are [ __ ] crazy the
Cuban sandwich is cool but they got two
chicken sandwiches that are insane and
then they're you know obviously they got
great uh pastries they got a guava
French toast [ __ ] delicious bro guava
French toast I'm not a big on the guava
bro I'm telling you I had like one of
the guava pastries from Porto's with the
cheese you gotta have it with the cheese
though I had it whatever it is the one
that they're known because one of them
is just just the guava on the other has
the cream cheese too you got to get the
the cream cheese to balance out the
jelly
hey I don't know man guava might not be
my fruit maybe maybe you need like some
strawberry jam oh yeah give me the
strawberry that [ __ ] basic as [ __ ]
give me the strawberry what's your wife
what is your wife she's Mexican and she
don't she cooks the [ __ ] out of food
yeah yeah does she make like handmade
tortillas and [ __ ] uh she can but I mean
it's not necessary it's kind of a lot to
make a handmade yeah she makes
everything else homemade she's very you
know my wife cooks all Sole and all that
yeah Mexican food is so different on the
west coast in New York because it's
really it's authentic yeah yeah New York
Mexican food is trash it's god-awful
it's awful bro it's so bad and so is
Florida Mexican food I lived in Tampa
and trying to find real Mexican food in
Tampa was [ __ ] it was the worst [ __ ]
ever I was like [ __ ] man I have to drive
like 45 minutes to this shitty little
taco stand and it was like good enough
but it wasn't great well they it's like
different tacos they like that's
terrible some like in New York they have
hard shell tacos bro I mean I look like
but like I'm talking about Old El Paso
they bought the shelves
it breaks yeah yeah [ __ ] that bro you
miss the East Coast hell yeah I missed
the East Coast really yeah yeah you
don't miss the East Coast well you're a
west coast boy you West Coast
East Coast was cool I only live in
Florida oh yeah I mean this is South
it's different Florida was cool I love
Florida the beach was nice the beaches
here suck well it depends more heroin
needles to dodge
LA's a [ __ ] open-air drug Market the
[ __ ] water's freezing
in Florida the waters piss warm and it's
clear and it's clear yeah beaches are
all sandy there might be some [ __ ]
you know there might be a couple Mega
hats on the beach but you know whatever
uh you know what man
right wing left wing same Bird yeah same
[ __ ] both of them are batshit crazy [ __ ]
dude if you go to the extreme right or
left it [ __ ] gets hairy on it either
walking line yeah I [ __ ] burn the whole
[ __ ] down just tell me what makes like
actual sense and that's what I support
does this make sense or is this batshit
crazy
hmm well you know what it is I feel like
politicians over the past five to ten
years have been less focused on policy
and more focused on like SEO and
clickbait yes and it's like they want to
make headlines yeah and they want to be
on Twitter they want to Trend and it's
like why don't you just
shut the [ __ ] up get something done yeah
go get something done like you all suck
they all suck yeah they all suck and I
used to be I mean I'm still a liberal
guy you know I voted for Joe Biden
um but God damn bro if this pandemic
hasn't made me like
feel like
what do we I'm looking on the other side
how these [ __ ] left
[ __ ] more crazy than these
right [ __ ] something crazy it's
crazy it's crazy and these people like
nobody has like their finger like on the
pulse of what's really going on
everybody or like normal people like why
don't we just [ __ ]
talk to the normal people who aren't
screaming on Twitter and showing up to
rallies oh my God just the normal
[ __ ] yeah it's bad it's so bad
on both sides like I'm embarrassed to be
I would be embarrassed to be either side
bro and listen I voted for Joe Biden I
hate Joe Biden but God damn yeah he's
been [ __ ] awful bro he's been awful
the way we pulled out of Afghanistan was
insane there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
yeah we got to keep him off bikes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's just delicious make him talk as
least as possible the economy's [ __ ]
Powell's [ __ ] horrible yelling's
[ __ ] horrible everything's [ __ ]
yeah but that being said
if you have some student debt at least
10 grand if it's been chauvignon see ya
see you later well you know inflation's
not a big deal
legislation's [ __ ] inflation is [ __ ]
yeah I hope they don't run them again I
think they will though you think what
run what he's a one-term president for
sure I don't know who he might not even
live through this term he's [ __ ]
demented
let's hope so I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm kidding
sucks because Kamala Harris ain't any
[ __ ] better she's bad too I haven't
even seen her speak she's Top Cop bro
she was incarcerating more people than
I don't know you know what's crazy
whoever is the first presidential
candidate that comes out and says
and just like imagine if Joe Biden
really wanted to win again yeah and if
Trump wanted to just grab all of the
left's votes they literally would come
out and just say we're going to make
marijuana federally legal and everyone
who's in prison for weed is getting
released that's what they need to do
everybody would vote for that person
normal people would be like
I mean well I mean I think you and I
were like from liberally leaning cities
yeah you go to the Midwest bro there's a
stark difference between the attitude I
feel like even the Rednecks I know love
weed yeah yeah they all [ __ ] smoke
weed and they all probably have cousins
that are in jail for weed offenses it's
like dude like
the war on drugs is just crazy in
general they need to like prohibition
has never worked for anything
historically ever right all I know is
what I knew about the War on Drugs when
I was a kid was all because of a mortal
technique yep and it's true but it's
like you have this [ __ ] going on with
the War on Drugs right you have families
being separated because it's only
hitting certain communities right you
have a whole black market economy that's
been created to like perpetuate this war
right in this endless [ __ ] uh
enemy-less War
and all it does is like keep people in
prison
keep you know the money printers on for
like the police the prison industry yeah
and it's like
it doesn't stop drug use would you be a
proponent of legalizing drugs legalize
all of it bro because people are [ __ ]
we're just talking about it I walked
through downtown Los Angeles right now
and I'm breathing in crack smoke anyways
right so at least if you decriminalize
it you could regulate it so you could be
regulated there could be places where
people aren't getting [ __ ] fentanyl
laced [ __ ] pills exactly and there's
no black market economy people getting
shot
cartel would be a lot less powerful yeah
because I think Mexico is about to
legalize I think I saw they were no no
no Colombia is legalizing cocaine why
not so that's gonna [ __ ] up it's their
entire economy anyway so they're gonna
legalize it it's Columbia I saw that all
drugs
and it makes sense because think about
all the violence that's used to support
the drug trade no for sure I think as
much as it might
push people to try drugs more
I think that you'll save a lot of lives
in the long run yep and there's also
like
with drug use there's a stigma right
with addiction right and if you start to
decriminalize or legalize in some cases
drugs like it it helps like if
chemically treating addiction worked
you could get a nicotine patch and stop
smoking cigarettes right yeah but
there's so many other things that
are factored into what keep you [ __ ]
stuck on a substance right you have the
social component you have the emotional
component and it's like
if you decriminalize things and you
start to destigmatize them at least it
allows you to re-socialize if you're an
addict yeah and I think too it also
removes the romanticization of it for
like a kid growing up because I know in
some countries where like the drinking
age is like 14 like there's like less
alcoholics I think it's Italy yeah it's
like yo like if people want to try [ __ ]
because they think it's like oh [ __ ] I'm
rebelling I'm [ __ ] I'm uh I'm gonna I
can't try this [ __ ] I'm gonna go fight
it but if it's like if it's just readily
available I think it'll make it like
less popular with kids which is kind of
weird to say no it makes perfect sense
because people want to do what they
can't do especially at that age like
human nature yep if you're a kid you're
trying to assert your Authority and
Independence right yeah so why wouldn't
you yeah it'd be no different than like
I mean look at the end of the day
alcohol is probably way more deadly than
a lot of drugs which is yeah maybe
except like fentanyl
opiates yeah I would say but like it's
probably more deadly than a mess
maybe I don't know about enough about
meth neither do I but I but I mean I
would venture to say that would alcohol
probably have killed more people every
year than meth I don't know we should
look that up
unless you're smoking [ __ ] fentanyl
Ace meth yeah which is where it's you
know but that's why you need to legalize
mess so you could regulate what you
should be able to just go to the store
and buy some [ __ ] Adderall well
that's what happens with drugs right
like if you're buying heroin on the
street it's strong on Tuesday so you
need two bundles but then on [ __ ]
Thursday it's week so you need six
bundles but then Friday you go to use
again it was week yesterday but they hit
you with the strong dose and they hit
you with that fetty and you're [ __ ]
dead yeah it's crazy yeah yeah I hope
you I mean I think like the thing about
uh you know pills and heroin and all
that I mean that [ __ ] if it's if it was
regulated if you could go somewhere I
know you're getting a safe dosage and
you know I feel like like it still sucks
you should try to get off of it for sure
but at the same time like either way
you're gonna get the drugs just now you
remove the
sharing needles HIV [ __ ] [ __ ] people
overdosing fat no you kind of remove a
lot of the um power from the cartel yep
yeah there's like and you're not going
to stop people from [ __ ] using drugs
you're not going to stop people from
using drugs we gotta stop the interview
tell you about our partners at Odd Socks
well first of all let's check out the
brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're a family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too it's an odd sock right
there that's awesome basic you know what
I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd Socks you
should too they got the crazy licenses
we're talking about Nickelodeon shout
out to Patrick [ __ ] Cheez-Its
Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
altogether bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course we're presented by
Odd Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview so
when is the new music coming out so
we're dropping creep with me October
28th that's the video the single I
[ __ ] it up so we're dropping creep
with me September 28th okay we're
dropping uh the video the week after and
it's just gonna be non-stop after that
and then the project before the end of
the year maybe project top of the Year
okay because you know the fourth fourth
quarter is kind of everything gets shut
down in December yeah music industry is
the [ __ ] worst bro yeah and even like
beginning of January you almost want to
like drop the third or fourth week of
January people little people go oh I'm
on vacation until Thanksgiving from
Thanksgiving to like April they're just
gone and what did it we don't even do
anything but socialize for work that's
our job yeah this [ __ ] makes no sense
yeah I might be one of those guys this
year for a month he just made that
choice I'm like I'm out everybody else
is off cool let's stack up some
interviews and I'm going to Mexico
okay you're gonna still be putting out
content yeah for sure no you can't take
off though you can't take all the way
off especially what I do you know bro
people take off like probably oh in the
music industry they're gone gone you
can't get nothing done the Spotify guys
take all everybody's off but why I don't
know man it's just kind of the norm in
the industry bro the industry needs to
be changed yeah I mean in a different a
bunch of different ways it used to be
changed it needs to be more favorable
for the artist it needs to be like more
productive you know who's doing a good
job as little Russell I'm familiar with
him like I've seen his freestyle his new
thing is
he's he built a venue at his house oh
that's fire already and in order to
attend you have to put an offer for your
ticket so then he goes and looks at all
of the offers and he picks whoever he
wants to accept so like he might have a
200 person show but make like 20 grand
in his backyard and when he goes on tour
he's going to do select cities and he's
only going to do that model for his
whole tour so if you're in like maybe he
does five cities right
10 cities whatever when you go see them
live you have to put an offer in for
your ticket and then you'll find out if
he accepts it
that's [ __ ] crazy that's super
interesting no promoters no split in the
house hey call the venue how much to
rent the venue Rents It Out takes it all
this is what my sound looks like can you
support what my setup is if not cool
we'll find a different venue I mean the
promoters nowadays they want you to do
all the [ __ ] on socials anyway so it's
like so it's like why not keep all the
money yeah exactly yeah so uh anything
else coming up man we uh I did a project
with the coyotes and dough man we got
that fire super fire yep those guys are
dope well both of them are I mean
coyotes are the two brothers are
incredible and no man's incredible super
dope and it's good like I like I've been
really rapping some Cypress Moreno
production on there you know we haven't
linked with him yet but his name's come
up a couple times I haven't met he works
with both of them a lot he's super dope
from La yeah
um yeah I definitely would like to reach
out to him um we got that we got the
breaking point two project I got tons of
videos I'm just going bro and like back
on your [ __ ] I'm back on my [ __ ] and
it's like I feel good well listen go run
up the uh uh September 28th is the video
September 28th creep with me on dsps in
the week later the video okay and then
uh we just dropped the freestyle that's
probably uh the other YouTube video that
you could see that's crazy yeah it's
fire I [ __ ] up a word but you didn't I
didn't don't listen don't even put that
out there because they won't notice not
let them I like it when people like yo
what the internet's the worst bro [ __ ]
them Emilio Rojas boom peace fire